have you ever heard of a company called
ge
you might not know them by name but i'm
sure you recognize their logo they're
that company that makes washers dryers
and refrigerators but did you know that
they were the world's largest company
not too long ago
in fact it was just 13 years ago that
they reached the top of the fortune 500.
yet today ge can't even turn a profit
it's actually been seven years since
they were consistently profitable
this has forced them to liquidate dozens
of subsidiaries at rock bottom prices
and reduce their workforce by over a
hundred thousand employees as recent as
2017 ge boasted over 300 000 employees
but today they only have about 168 000
all of this has cost the ge stock to
tumble 85 percent from their peak
shedding nearly 400 billion dollars in
market cap things have gotten so bad
that ge resorted to doing a reverse talk
split of 1 to 8 just last year and if
you weren't already convinced that ge
was getting destroyed just listen to
this
ge was the original member of the dow
jones and they have continuously been
part of the index since 1907 but in 2018
the dow jones kicked out ge
i'm not sure they could have been
insulted it any more than this
so here's how ge they priced a
multi-hundred billion fortune before a
newborn could become a teenager
while g's fundamental crisis didn't
become evident until the last 10 years
ge has actually been making bad moves
for over 40 years it all started in 1981
when a man named jack welch became the
ceo of the company jack came from a
rather humble family his father was a
regular old railroad conductor while his
mother was a homemaker this meant that
throughout his childhood he worked
several odd jobs including being a golf
caddy a newspaper delivery boy a shoe
salesman and a drill press operator and
when he joined the ge in 1916 he was
simply a junior chemical engineer
considering this blue collar background
you would think that jack was
sympathetic to the struggles of everyday
americans and that he would treat his
employees really well but jack was
actually the exact opposite he was
ruthless rash and rather heartless in
fact by the time jack became a
well-known businessman most people would
come neutron jack because he was like a
neutron bomb but wait a minute what did
jack even do to receive such a title
well he was basically the mastermind
behind all of the worst parts of
capitalism for example he was the one
that popularized the rank and the inc
policy this is when you fire the bottom
10 percent of your workforce every
single year if this sounds familiar to
you it's probably because you've heard
of amazon adopting the same policy while
this strategy might sound reasonable at
first glance it leads to terrible
long-term performance here's the thing
when you're constantly firing the bottom
10 percent of your workforce your
employees are never able to focus on the
big picture they're always worried about
surviving next year's cuts this was
especially true amongst management which
led to cooking the books
now they weren't doing anything illegal
per se at least at the beginning but
they were manipulating the numbers
through every loophole they could find
for example let's say you were the
manager of a department at ge and your
goal is to achieve a million dollars in
profit this quarter
last quarter this department only pulled
a nine hundred thousand dollars in
profit so you have to increase profit by
roughly 10 percent ideally you would
look for ways to grow the revenue that
your department brought in but this
would take multiple quarters if not
years
so instead you decide to simply fire 10
employees that are being paid a few
thousand a month this allows your
department to beat the vein metric of a
million dollars in profit however your
department is nowhere near as strong as
a one million dollar department should
be and this wasn't just happening here
and there it was happening company wide
from the top down and jack was the most
infamous for it he didn't bolster the
company's profits by firing people but
he did boast the company's balance sheet
by firing people
for example let's say you want to make a
billion dollar acquisition you could
wait a few years for the company to
build up sufficient cash reserves or you
could just fire five percent of your
workforce and use their payrolls to fund
the purchase and that's exactly what
jack did it throughout his tenure
jack was only ceo for 20 years but
within this time he made 600
acquisitions
this works out to 30 acquisitions per
year or two and a half acquisitions
every single month
obviously this is by no means naturally
sustainable looking back it's obvious
why ge eventually got destroyed but at
the time it looked like ge was crushing
it given jack's strict department-wide
goals the company would always beat wall
street's earnings expectations by at
least one cent per share
on top of this their assets were growing
exponentially thanks to all of the
acquisitions which sent the company's
stock to the moon when jack took over in
1981 the company was only worth 14
billion dollars but when he left in 2001
it was worth 410 billion dollars but
jack didn't build a true 410 billion
dollar company what he built was a
machine that could consistently top wall
street's expectations also the company
was not filled with loyal employees who
were excited to build up the company
instead it was basically filled with
contractors who are good at playing the
purging game this toxic culture was
synonymous with ge by the time jack left
and though the company was doing well on
paper is fundamentally weaker than ever
before
and it just took one economic downturn
to topple the house of cards
by now i'm sure you're all familiar with
what happened in 2008 the great
financial recession now you might think
that ge was relatively safe from this
given that they mainly deal with
physical products like appliances so
while sales could go down and there were
no risk of facing a real crisis right
well this would have been the case if
ges stuck to their original business but
jack had expanded ge into basically
every industry you can think of
including the financial industry their
financial subsidiary was called the ge
capital and they were the fifth largest
lender in the us
given what happened to lenders in 2008
this was already a terrible position to
be in but this was just half the story
you see while many banks overextended
themselves and engaged in self-prime
lending at least they had deposits they
just landed out these deposits in bad
ways
ge however didn't even have deposits
they borrowed money through commercial
papers at low interest rates and then
lended that money to people at higher
interest rates ge even bragged about
being the largest borrower of a
commercial paper
at the time they accounted for four
percent of all commercial paper in the
us for perspective g's entire debt load
translated to over half a trillion
dollars personally i don't think this
was something to brag about because when
the financial crisis hit they were
screwed on both ends they couldn't
collect payments from borrowers nor
could they pay off their own debts and
pretty soon they needed a bailout now i
know a lot of you guys love to criticize
the big banks for getting bailouts of 10
to 30 billion dollars but all of that is
nothing in comparison to what ge got ge
didn't get a bailout worth 10 20 or even
50 billion dollars their bailout was
worth the disgusting of 139
billion dollars
so if anyone deserves criticism for
bailouts it's these guys this bailout
didn't really help turn around the
company either as the company was
already rotten to the core it basically
just ensured that the company didn't go
under in a matter of weeks
ever since the bailout ge has only been
on a decline regardless of what metric
you look at they've literally only
gotten destroyed
their assets are down from 781 billion
dollars to 185 billion dollars their
cash reserves are down from 120 billion
dollars to 20 billion
their revenue is down from 150 billion
to 75 billion
and as for their net income well it's
not even positive this isn't that
surprising given that ge has just been
downsizing it ever since the bailout ge
has basically sold everything even
including their appliance business so if
you bought a ge appliance in the past
six years it wasn't even made by ge
themselves it was actually made by a
chinese company called hair who has
rights to the ge brand
at this point ge themselves are only
involved in three industries which are
aviation healthcare and energy and ge is
planning on spinning these off into
three different companies as well
the healthcare spin-off is supposed to
take place in early 2023 and the energy
spin-off is supposed to take place in
early 2024
this means that the original ge will
only be left with the aviation industry
this is honestly quite a shame given how
large ge was just a decade ago the only
good thing that has happened to ge over
the past decade is their debt has also
gone down their long-term debt has
decreased from 336 billion dollars to 27
billion dollars similarly their total
liabilities have decreased from 656
billion dollars to 150 billion dollars
while this is far better than the
position that they used to be in it it's
still not all that great g's market cap
currently sits at 80 billion dollars
which means that the total liabilities
is still nearly twice their market cap
so ge still has quite a ways to go
in terms of what ge will look like after
the spin-offs it's just even more
disappointing in the past 6 months ge
pulled in a total revenue of 35 billion
dollars out of which 11.7 billion came
from the aerospace segment this means
that the aerospace segment roughly
accounts for a third of their business
given that their market cap is currently
80 billion dollars once the health care
and energy businesses are spun off the
market cap will be closer to 26 billion
dollars and 26 billion 202 dollars is
equivalent to just eight billion
nineteen ninety-one dollars when jack
took over in 1981 the company was worth
14 billion dollars which means that in
just two years ge will be worth less
than what they are worth way back in
1981.
now that's truly quite a tumble
despite ge's terrible current position
some people are hopeful that splitting
up and focusing on just one industry is
exactly what ge needs the aviation
industry is still very much recovering
from the pandemic slump so demand for
aircraft should only go up in the coming
years not to mention it g's other
segments are starting to make a
turnaround as well for example ge power
is finally profitable again and the
focus on renewable energy could pay off
big in the coming decades similarly as
supply chain issues finally cool down ge
healthcare is expected to boost margins
in the high teens so it looks like net
profitability is actually possible for
ge in the coming years but don't let
these short-term outlooks fool you sure
this could be the bottom for ge but it's
not like they're poised to launch the
iphone or become a leader in ai
really all they'll be doing is salvaging
their existing businesses and finally
making them profitable again in other
words they're just back to ground zero
their time at the top isn't helping them
in any way if anything it simply
burdened them with debt which they're
still trying to pay off so at this point
their chances of recovering to their
former glory is just as good as any
other company with their same market cap
in fact g's chances are probably worse
because of the remaining debt and lack
of momentum so what can we learn from
this well the takeaway seems to be that
the second a company starts to value
shareholders over customers they've
initiated their eventual demise they
might end up posting good numbers on
paper for years or even decades but
their fundamentally flawed approach does
eventually catch up and by the time they
realize it it's already way too late so
if you're a business owner make sure you
don't put profits over customers because
that's a surefire way to get screwed but
that's just what i think do you think ge
deserve their downfall comment that down
below
also drop a like if you're not a fan of
g's bailout and of course consider
checking out our discord community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
subscribing and see more questions
logically answered but until then
i'm hurry and i'll see you guys on the
next one